and welcome to Hannity now tonight
Democrats the media mob they are focused
on one thing and one thing only and that
is the one Riot that took place on
January 6th 2021 not the 574 riots in
the summer of 2020. it's literally all
they have they're clinging to it and
abortion like Manna From Heaven the only
political issues they think they have
they have taken every word of this
week's double hearsay witness as
complete gospel truth they have raced to
the finish line and many on the media
mob in particular many in Congress have
announced that former president Donald J
Trump is guilty of everything she
accused him of never mind the many
reports that two Secret Service agents
deny her allegation that Donald Trump
trump tried to commandeer the vehicle
that he was being driven in never mind
that one of President Trump's attorney
says even though she testified under
oath it was her handwriting it's my
handwriting and again she did that under
oath never mind that the president
president Trump's denials that he ever
wanted to waive armed people into the
rally he's denied it uh how about we do
a few simple things for once and not
rush to judgment and maybe give people
the benefit of the doubt and let's do
these three things let's have one a
Secret Service agents let him sign sworn
affidavits they don't even have to go
before cameras and give up their careers
two how about we do this why don't we
hire the best professional handwriting
experts because I would I've bet a lot
of money that they'll be able to
determine whether or not it was Trump's
lawyer or the hearsay witness who
actually wrote the notes that they refer
to in the hearings this week and how
about number three how about we see if
any of the people that were Manning the
metal detectors were ever asked to stop
doing their jobs and we can put them
before the cameras then the committee
they can investigate whether the
president authorized the National Guard
as four people with the president on
January 4th have said to us right here
on this program they witnessed him doing
it this is an amazing distraction though
for the Democrats and their press
secretaries in the media mob because
their policies are failing on a
spectacular and unprecedented level so
they don't have to talk about that
because they'll just stick to January 6.
now their president his radical party is
a disaster for the entire country now as
a result America's economy is
historically bad the Dow just had its
worst six months to start a year since
1962. the s p is off to there were start
since 1970 and the NASDAQ they've had
their worst start ever now meanwhile
breaking today the Atlanta fed is
projecting that our economy will
officially be in a recession by July
remember it's defined by two quarters of
negative growth growth remember a few
days ago the administration was they
were telling us not to worry about a
recession that it was not inevitable of
course these are the same Geniuses that
promised that inflation was transitory
the same Geniuses who seemed to believe
that some kind of magical transition to
wind and solar is unfolding before our
eyes and will bring us to the renewable
energy Independence Promised Land
because Joe and his radical new green
deal socialists they promised us they
would eliminate American fossil fuels
now when they said they would eliminate
fossil fuels they didn't say only
domestic fossil fuels because they have
no problem importing let's see Russian
oil
OPEC nations oil Saudi Arabian oil
they're open to importing oil from
Venezuela and I hear they even took a
million barrels of oil from Iran last
year now clearly they have no idea what
they're doing and the pain and the
suffering of these radical policies and
all that pain that's causing every
American now and earlier today when Joe
Biden was asked how long Americans would
need to fit the bill for these Rising
gas prices Joe Biden just Shrugged it
off and said well as long as it takes
take a look
we are going to support Ukraine as long
as it takes
look at the impact that the war on
Ukraine has had on Russia
they've had to renege on their national
debt for the first time since the
beginning almost well over 100 years
they've lost 15 years of the gains they
made in terms of their economy they're
in a situation where they're having
trouble because of my imposition of of
uh uh
dealing with what can be exported to
Russia in terms of Technology they can't
even you know they're having they're
going to have trouble maintaining oil
production because they don't have the
technology to do it they need American
Technology
where's the sense of urgency the sense
of of capturing the moment and helping
the American people apparently Joe Biden
doesn't feel your pain maybe he just
thinks everyone flies around the world
collecting millions of dollars from
oligarchs and Bad actors in Russia or
the Bank of China or oil and gas
companies in Ukraine like his son zero
experienced hunter or maybe Joe Biden
simply doesn't care or doesn't even know
now as we all know there is one person
and one person only who decreased
America's domestic supply of oil and gas
it wasn't Vladimir Putin it was Joe
Biden Joe Biden doesn't care about the
truth just listen to the president's
pretty deranged speech in Europe when he
somehow managed to attack the U.S
Supreme Court all while lying once again
about inflation take a look
we have the strongest economy in the
world our inflation rates are lower than
other nations in the world the one thing
that has been destabilizing is the
outrageous behavior of the Supreme Court
of the United States
an overruling not only Roe v Wade but
essentially challenging the right to
privacy we've been a leader in the world
in terms of personal rights and privacy
rights and it is a mistake in my view
for the Supreme Court to do what it did
I can understand why the American people
are frustrated because of what the
Supreme Court did I can understand why
the American people are frustrated
because of inflation
oh in truth we got to remind you Joe
wasn't a leader in civil rights because
Joe partnered with the former klansman
named Robert Byrd and tried to stop the
integration of public schools he didn't
want the schools in his words to become
racial jungles so let's help educate Joe
Biden because he's deeply confused as
everybody knows every single other
country in the G7 has a lower inflation
rate than our country the USA in fact
almost every single country in the
developed world has a lower rate
including Canada Germany France Italy
Japan Saudi Arabia and I can keep going
and by the way for Joe to attack one of
America's greatest institutions the U.S
Supreme Court while on foreign soil
that's pretty low even for Joe but don't
take my word for it listen to Joe Biden
himself because he said it in 2017. take
a listen
what worries me most and I never thought
I'd have to make this speech or want to
make this speech
the almost drumbeat of denigration of
the institutional structures that govern
us
is dangerous
when you delegitimize the courts
you delegitimize the legislative body
it does raise a lot of questions does uh
Joe Biden hold any real principles or
values other than enriching himself his
family and going to Delaware every other
weekend well pretty much every weekend
the country's falling apart Joe Biden is
just daughtering along doing whatever is
far left advisors tell them to do and
it's now so bad even top Democrats
they're voicing their concerns tonight
according to a poll conducted by the AP
a vast majority of Democrats 78 percent
think this country our country is headed
in the wrong direction under Joe Biden
that's Democrats his real clear politics
average has Joe's approval under 38
percent the lowest point in his
presidency by the way that includes
outlier polls they give him very high
approval ratings that are not real
former Obama adviser David Axelrod is
now venting about Joe Biden even on fake
news CNN take a look
when the president got into those
questions gas prices and inflation and
abortion rights there was a lot less of
that certainty a lot less of that
emphatic nature of his initial
presentation on NATO because he doesn't
have great answers
well it's embarrassing for Joe Biden the
Democratic party but so much worse for
the American people that are struggling
to fill up their gas tanks and put food
on the table because we have a human
vegetable that probably doesn't know
what day of the week it is today as
president and of course he's surrounded
by a bunch of radical woke staffers uh
who don't know anything about the
economy or energy or anything else so if
we're serious if Joe Biden is not
mentally or physically up to the job he
should retire now a full 59 percent a
new poll of Americans see exactly what
I've been telling you since the campaign
I was kind of the lone voice out there
saying this guy is weak and frail in a
cognitive mess wasn't hard to spot now
59 percent of Americans see it think
about this Joe Biden almost never takes
questions from the press the only sit
down TV interview in the past six months
was Jimmy Kimmel wasn't exactly a barn
burner either according to Politico the
White House avoids using the Oval Office
for press events because they don't have
a teleprompter and look at your screen
during meetings Biden is relying on
giant note cards like that say say hello
then sit in your seat
okay so ask yourself if you can't have a
conversation without a note card or do a
q a without a teleprompter are you
really capable of being the president of
the United States of America I would
argue the hardest job in the world now
in the coming months as America now
battles this recession stagflation and
probably worse as we battle spiking gas
prices Energy prices Biden is now set to
give one major address about the economy
wrong January 6th hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else